here's the thing I'm this isn't
hemispheric so I don't even know this is
gonna work I don't even know if I'm
gonna be able to enjoy the summer update
there it is thinking you're swimming a
yes so first things first you'll want to
put on a suitable wetsuit like mmhmm
snorkel mask what's the place oh my god
look at me okay look at my little ladies
I'm freakin swimming get that good today
get any more perfect absolutely this
swimming is very slow oh my gosh I have
a swimming champion so you can't get out
on the rocks the hole here we go oh
we're gonna try again that was a little
disappointing here we go to save the day
oh shoot okay so one out of three right
before you get there you hit a oh hey
Pascale what do you want you could have
anything wait you're gonna give me
something stick that in your skillet and
let it simmer I think that Pascal is
delusional I'm a little concerned
I made wall look at all this stuff I
need we're gonna stop I'm into it but
like I wonder if I you know a sea slug
I'm kind of salty about that whoa whoa
oh hello sea star maybe it'll give me an
autograph could I catch I can't catch
meteors in the water you should be able
to catch meteors in the water this is an
oyster Oh
a whelk let's freaking swim guys we're
swimmin we were gonna swim into our
little eggies can't swim anymore oh we
have a scallop mmm scallop okay I want
this wait
you get clap in the water this is a big
boy what are you fast little dude can't
break the grip it's going so fast stop
swimming you Pig
so maybe if I just keep going and
swimming here I'll swim ahead of it and
then I dive oh my gosh it's so fast oh
my god now you're going this way this is
so cruel this is ridiculous
I've got a drowned now I'm gonna lose
track of where it's going turn around
yeah every now and then I suck kick my
little leg ease I will not give up on
this cuz I need you now more than ever
I'm gonna drown out here what is
happening this is making me really
furious like I'm trying to get ahead of
it oh my god were so close for so close
so close so close come on this is insane
like I can't freaking catch this thing
oh my god I was going this way we got it
we got it we got it we got it we got it
we got it we got it we got it snow crab
snow crab that crab is ridiculous
I'm not keeping scallops for him oops
I'm sure I'll catch another we got to
find some more scallops because I have
messed up and sold them Pascal pops up
oh look I caught a scallop mm-hmm
the fork is right here I mean I'm not
really picking up any hobbies I mean I
guess is streaming a new hobby I mean
this is okay this is hurting it's is
hurting it's stuck in my hair now it's
pulling my hair oh no this is really not
good please be perfect please be perfect
we don't gonna close the game bye I just
don't know how I've made it this long
without like listening to kpop what did
you guys send me a leaf print what oh my
God look at my outfit and I got a golf
bag this is great we're going gulping I
missed the circle oh that's cool that's
nice
he's a snow crab because you know why
well guys thank you so much for watching
I hope that you enjoyed the stream I
always have such a fun time with you
guys you're all awesome and now I'm
gonna see if any of my friends are on
[Music]